c'est une évidence géographique qu'il
est bon de rappeler de temps en temps le
nord de la france c'est déjà le grand
sud pour un certain nombre d'européens
c'est le cas notamment des britanniques
qui ont fait des plages de la côte
d'opale et notamment du touquet leur
riviera c'est une tradition déjà qu'ils
aient respecté cette année encore rien
de masse le premier débarquement des
anglais au touquet c'était il ya un
siècle
quelques propriétaires décidé d'y
développer une station balnéaire depuis
beaucoup de britanniques comme gloria et
ont élu domicile il n'y avait pas
d'aéroport tous qu'il n'y avait pas de
bus ni de train non plus en fait il n'y
avait pas vraiment de moyen d'y arriver
si vous n'aviez pas de voiture et puis
mon mari cherchait depuis longtemps un
endroit 30 rens
et comme beaucoup d'anglais ils sont
tombés amoureux de la station et de son
modèle fétiche le westminster il a été
construit par les anglais pour les
anglais puisqu'à cette époque les jeux
étaient interdits en angleterre est la
première destination possible que la
haute société puisse jouer au casino est
effectivement la france est le touquet
en particulier fait aujourd'hui on
essaye
de plus en plus de coller effectivement
à ce dimanche pour qu'il retrouve
exactement les sensations qu'ils avaient
tué une certaine banque à l'année c'est
un bourreau 65 % de la clientèle passage
ils ont un sens nombre de petits groupes
on appelle en anglais des golfs cities
qui viennent ici depuis 10 20 ou 30 ans
et nous allons les garder le fiche
technique en précisant les repas le ty
apéritif qui a pu avoir
l'organisation la soirée et ont fait une
chose bien d'être en france mais on aime
aussi sentir un peu l'influencé
britannique prochaine fois tu ne viens
pas pour la plage ici il n'ya que le
golf qui nous intéresse pas de la
cuisine française
à deux heures de londres c'est la french
riviera on estime à 20% le nombre de
villas possédées par des anglais une
architecture de manoir de bord de mer
pas tape-à-l'oeil où se cachent des
trésors
la chasse au trésor dans les rues du
touquet c'est un grand classique toute
l'année pour des centaines de petits
anglais il faut chercher une maison qui
a un anglais et elle est là on a trouvé
elle s'appelle butterfly c'est juste
pour que les enfants soient sensibles à
ce qu'il voit on les fait chercher
traduire quelques noms travailler à
l'école avant oui quelques-uns ont
préparé des choses
un autre groupe était déjà revenue la
côte d'opale c'est la porte d'entrée des
britanniques dans la région chaque année
ils sont plus d'un million à y passer et
ainsi plaire peu importe la météo
et comme dit un proverbe anglais sera de
badoit d' agent klaus ce n'est pas le
temps qui est mauvais c'est juste que
les vêtements sont pas tout à fait
adapté